Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
[Azione chiama, genera,
crea, ispira azione]
[Il conto alla rovescia
non lascia scampo]
[Possiamo fermare
il cambiamento climatico]
Salve a tutti.
Come state, tutto bene?
Io sto bene, in questo momento
abbastanza particolare, no?
Anche perché vi vedo tutti
con le mascherine...
Io non tanto,
perché tre giorni fa sono stato infettato.
E oggi sono ammalato di Covid.
Però tranquilli, eh:
vedo nelle vostre espressioni
un attimo di paura -
no, tranquilli, perché siamo
a oltre due metri di distanza,
siamo abbastanza distanti tra di noi
e quindi siamo sicuri.
Cioè, tenendo le distanze,
come in questo caso,
la mia capacità di infettarvi
è praticamente zero.
Cioè l'indice di infezione, l'R0,
è sostanzialmente zero.
Ora supponiamo, invece,
di prendere questa pallina
che chiamerò PM 10,
come le polveri che abbiamo nell'aria,
e che sono legate
all'inquinamento, insomma.
Come stai, PM10, tutto bene?
Etcì.
Ho infettato il PM10.
Scusatemi: adesso non posso più fare
la presentazione che pensano di fare.
Devo cambiare necessariamente
la PM10, ma non posso tenerla qui.
C'è qualcuno che vuole prendere
la mia PM 10? C'è qualcuno? Nessuno?
Scusa, potresti prendere
la mia PM 10, ti dispiace?
Ecco, grazie.
Grazie mille, grazie.
Non è riuscita a prenderla.
È mia moglie.
Siamo congiunti da molto tempo,
quindi non ci sono problemi.
Ecco: banalmente, con questo gesto,
io ho infettato una persona
a una distanza superiore a due metri,
cioè quella distanza di sicurezza
a cui io sono in questo momento
in realtà non è proprio
così esattamente sicura,
perché ci possono essere
elementi ambientali
che mi portano a contaminare una persona
anche a distanze più lunghe.
Il mio R0 è passato da zero a uno.
Ora supponiamo, invece,
di prendere casualmente
questo cestino di PM10.
Non è tanto casuale, in realtà,
Come state PM10, tutto bene?
Mi accompagnano sempre,
perché le PM accompagnano un po' tutti.
Etciù!
Ecco, adesso ho un piccolo problema:
ho contaminato tutte le mie PM10.
Ora capite che se io, in questo momento,
gettassi le PM10 su di voi,
io potrei rischiare di contaminare
molte persone contemporaneamente,
più di una.
Quindi il mio R0 è passato
da uno a tre, quattro.
Ora supponiamo, invece,
di mettere un ostacolo tra me e voi.
Per esempio un albero, una pianta.
Se io, a questo punto,
facessi lo stesso gesto,
cioè gettassi le mie PM10,
vedete che l'albero
tratterrebbe le mie PM10
e le farebbe ricadere
nella mia prossimità.
Cioè quello che noi facciamo
quando non ci sono gli alberi
e ci mettiamo, per esempio,
una mascherina.
La mascherina ha lo stesso effetto
che dovrebbe avere una pianta, un albero.
Questo succede perché i virus,
nel loro serbatoio naturale,
stanno proprio nelle foreste,
dove abbiamo i pipistrelli, i pangolini
e tutti gli animali selvatici.
Si scambiano nelle foreste,
gli animali, questi virus;
e noi, per poter entrare
in contatto con questi virus,
dobbiamo necessariamente entrare
in questi serbatoi naturali.
Oppure, lasciare che gli animali selvatici
possano uscire dai loro serbatoi naturali
e venire in contatto con noi,
come probabilmente è successo
nell'ultima epidemia.
E quindi diciamo che il serbatoio naturale
è estremamente importante,
cioè va preservato
perché se no il rischio
è che il numero di pandemie
possa aumentare nel tempo.
Ora, circa 100 anni fa è iniziata
la Seconda Rivoluzione Industriale.
La Seconda Rivoluzione Industriale,
nella storia dell'uomo,
è quando abbiamo cominciato
a utilizzare il petrolio e il gas
in grandissime quantità.
Considerate che la nostra astronave,
100 anni fa,
aveva il serbatoio pieno
di combustibili fossili:
una quantità di energia illimitata,
per il miliardo di persone
che c'erano in quel momento.
La temperatura della nostra astronave
era perfetta, intorno a 14 gradi,
come doveva essere;
e la pressione del manometro
dell'anidride carbonica nell'aria
anch'esso era assolutamente normale:
attorno a 270 parti per milione,
che vuol dire 270 milligrammi
per mille litri d'aria.
Quindi, diciamo che era
una condizione ideale;
ma era anche una condizione ideale
per cominciare a svilupparci,
e infatti attorno agli anni '60
abbiamo avuto quello che si chiama
il boom economico.
Cioè abbiamo cominciato a utilizzare
tutta questa quantità di energia
che avevamo nel serbatoio
proprio per vendere auto -
la Cinquecento, per esempio, in Italia -
riscaldare le nostre case
e cominciare a costruire oggetti,
dispositivi, elettrodomestici
che abbiamo portato ovunque;
e abbiamo realizzato
anche tutte le imprese
in grado di produrre questi dispositivi.
Cioè abbiamo proprio avuto un'esplosione.
Ora siamo passati
da un miliardo di persone
a quattro, cinque miliardi.
Fino al 2010 in cui
siamo diventati oltre sette miliardi!
Cioè anche l'uomo, con tutta
questa energia a disposizione,
è proprio cresciuto, si è sviluppato;
e sviluppandosi, ha dovuto cominciare
a occupare il territorio.
E infatti, noi abbiamo cominciato
Vedete: nella prima fotografia
è la provincia di Padova negli anni '60;
nella seconda fotografia
è la stessa provincia di Padova nel 2010.
Cioè siamo proprio andati
a invadere le nicchie naturali,
perché era necessario
per poter ospitare tutti gli uomini.
Ora, quello che abbiamo fatto
negli ultimi 100 anni
è uno sfruttamento
indiscriminato delle risorse.
Abbiamo proprio prosciugato il serbatoio:
e lì dove abbiamo estratto
le risorse, abbiamo inquinato.
Questo inquinamento l'abbiamo anche
portato nelle nostre città.
Attraverso i dispositivi
con cui noi abitiamo le nostre città:
le auto, il riscaldamento;
fuori dalle città
abbiamo anche le industrie.
Cioè abbiamo proprio creato
una condizione quasi ideale,
e nello stesso tempo siamo andati
proprio a invadere i serbatoi naturali.
Questa, per esempio,
è la deforestazione del Borneo.
Ormai il Borneo l'abbiamo
deforestato a oltre il 50%,
cioè quella foresta pluviale
l'abbiamo abbattuta
per andare a coltivare palme
per produrre olio di palma;
e noi, attraverso l'olio di palma,
ci alimentiamo per esempio
le automobili, per il biodiesel,
oltre che a metterlo, in parte,
anche nell'alimentare;
ma in buona parte, adesso,
finisce proprio nel biodiesel
per alimentare le automobili.
Oppure siamo andati
a deforestare l'Amazzonia,
perché siamo cresciuti tanto:
siamo carnivori, ci piace la carne,
abbiamo bisogno di allevare bestiame
a livello mondiale.
E quindi abbiamo deforestato l'Amazzonia
per... realizzare pascoli!
Sì, l'uomo ha fatto anche questo.
E cosa è successo?
Ogni volta che noi facciamo
un'operazione di questo tipo,
e distruggiamo quel serbatoio naturale,
quella nicchia naturale,
gli animali a quel punto escono.
Con la loro dote di virus.
Infatti i virus stanno via via aumentando;
e poi i virus entrano
in contatto con l'uomo,
perché a quel punto si sono -
abbiamo tolto le barriere,
e abbiamo quello che si chiama, appunto,
lo spillover, oppure passaggio di specie.
O anche la zoonosi,
come si chiama tecnicamente,
cioè quando il virus passa
dall'animale all'uomo.
Ora, passando dall'animale all'uomo
questo virus viene poi trasportato,
attraverso gli uomini
e i loro dispositivi,
in tutto il mondo: aeroplani, navi, auto.
Oggi noi possiamo portare un virus
da una parte all'altra del mondo
in 12 ore:
una persona contaminata può contaminare
un continente in 12 ore.
Capite che è una cosa straordinaria?
Dopodiché, il virus entra
nelle nostre città.
E trova proprio una condizione ideale:
quegli assembramenti che lui vuole.
Eh sì, perché il cinema,
le sale come queste, gli stadi.
Oppure qualsiasi altro - i supermercati.
Tutto è un assembramento:
e il virus a quel punto,
a neanche due metri di distanza
può trasferirsi a velocità fotonica.
Non solo: lui entra nelle nostre città,
e noi, quando respiriamo,
respiriamo in mezzo alle PM10.
Eh sì, perché le generiamo, le creiamo;
e quindi lui si trova
un bellissimo veicolo,
come abbiamo visto prima,
per poter andare più distante.
Eh già.
Dopodiché, la conseguenza
è l'ultima fotografia che voi vedete lì.
La conseguenza è che abbiamo un'epidemia.
E la conseguenza dell'epidemia
è che finiamo all'ospedale,
e molti di noi, da quell'ospedale,
non riescono più a uscire.
Questo è un fenomeno
assolutamente naturale,
che però noi tendenzialmente favoriamo.
Ora, qual è la velocità
di diffusione di un virus?
Beh, la velocità di diffusione
di un virus è un po' subdola,
perché non è proprio la stessa velocità
con cui noi gestiamo i tempi
nelle nostre società
o nella nostra vita,
che è tendenzialmente lineare.
Il virus ha un'altra
tipologia di andamento,
che è quello molto naturale,
di tutti gli eventi naturali.
La prima settimana
il virus si può diffondere,
e può contaminare
400 persone, 500 persone.
La seconda settimana,
da 500 persone è passata a 1600 persone;
la terza settimana,
da 1600 sono diventate 3.500,
e noi cominciamo leggermente
a preoccuparci,
perché nella prima settimana si diceva:
vabbè sarà un'influenzina,
ma non sarà poi così grave;
e poi c'è qualcuno
che è infettato, ma insomma -
Magari non facciamo
abbastanza tamponi.
La quarta settimana,
gli infettati diventano 10.000.
Al giorno, magari.
E la quinta settimana diventano 100.000,
ed è quando diventano 100.000
che cominciamo a vedere
le terapie intensive piene,
le persone portate all'ospedale.
E ci prendiamo paura:
ci prendiamo talmente paura
che chiudiamo tutto.
Ci separiamo, ci distanziamo,
e il nostro R0, da quattro, cinque
che era, torna uno, zero.
Ci mettiamo la mascherina,
e il nostro R0, da quattro, cinque
torna a diventare uno.
Cioè facciamo tutte quelle
operazioni di adattamento
che ci servono per salvaguardare
la nostra vita e quella degli altri.
Però il professore è un burlone.
Lo dico con me stesso.
È un burlone,
perché è quello che voi
vedete qui non è il virus.
Eh, troppo facile dire che è un virus.
Eh, però sembra uguale!
È iniziato in Italia,
poi dopo comincia a estendersi
negli altri paesi, poi -
non è il virus.
Perché quello che voi
vedete qui, in realtà,
è l'effetto dei cambiamenti climatici.
Sono gli eventi estremi che noi abbiamo.
E gli eventi estremi sono
le tempeste, gli uragani, i tornado,
le bombe d'acqua, le inondazioni.
Guardate: tra il 1970 e il 1980
erano circa 462, sono stati;
cioè 46 all'anno.
Tra il 1980 e il 1990
erano già 160 all'anno.
Tra il 1990 e il 2000
erano già diventati oltre 300 - 350.
Tra il 2000 e il 2010
erano diventati oltre un migliaio,
gli eventi estremi.
Nell'ultimo decennio,
sono stati oltre 10.000 all'anno.
E infatti ci sorprendiamo, oggi,
che ogni volta che viene a piovere
c'è qualche città che va sotto,
c'è qualche fiume che esonda,
e quasi ci sorprendiamo, no?
È tra quei 10.000 all'anno lì, eh!:
questo non succedeva, negli anni '70.
Questi sono proprio quegli effetti
legati al cambiamento climatico,
che ci dice che ogni cinque anni
gli eventi estremi raddoppiano.
Vuol dire che nel 2025
saranno 20.000 all'anno;
nel 2030 saranno 40.000 all'anno.
E allora avremo talmente paura
per gli effetti che avranno
i cambiamenti climatici,
che andremo in "lockdown ambientale".
Ma il lockdown ambientale
è leggermente diverso
perché il lockdown ambientale
non è mettersi una mascherina,
non è distanziamento.
Vuol dire rinforzare tutto,
bloccare tutto;
e questo è quello che succede,
perché oggi si è accesa una lampadina.
Oggi siamo qui perché si è accesa
una lampadina, un warning,
che dice: il nostro serbatoio è vuoto.
Non abbiamo più energia per tutti.
La temperatura della nostra astronave
è salita a 15 gradi.
La pressione, il manometro della CO2,
ha superato 400 parti per milione.
Qualsiasi ingegnere di processo,
di fronte a un impianto che è
ad alta temperatura e ad alta pressione,
senza la possibilità di controllarlo
da un punto di vista energetico,
ha due sole possibilità.
O scappa, come hanno fatto a Chernobyl:
sono scappati, a un certo punto.
Troppo pericoloso.
Oppure, se è coraggioso,
si attacca alla manopola di emergenza
e tira giù la manopola,
per mettere in sicurezza l'impianto.
Ora, questo è cosa si può fare.
Bene: questo che dobbiamo fare è semplice.
È la call to action: ne abbiamo parlato,
oggi, quasi dappertutto.
Se la conseguenza
di quello che stiamo vivendo
è dovuta alla Seconda
Rivoluzione Industriale,
ed è dovuta ai combustibili fossili,
l'unica altra alternativa che abbiamo,
senza se e senza ma,
è che dobbiamo abbandonare
i combustibili fossili.
Cioè dobbiamo abbandonare
il petrolio, il gas ed il carbone.
Non c'è niente da fare.
L'alternativa ai combustibili fossili
è quella che voi vedete
in questa immagine qua: il Sole.
Il Sole ci dà 15.000 volte
l'energia necessaria:
è il più grande serbatoio che abbiamo,
possiamo riempire di nuovo
il serbatoio della nostra astronave.
Durerà quattro miliardi di anni:
è molto sostenibile.
Abbiamo tutte le tecnologie
per poterlo prendere;
ma diventa scomodo, perché
dobbiamo cambiare i dispositivi.
Auto elettriche, case elettriche -
tante volte non siamo pronti.
Questo vuol dire
che abbiamo due possibilità.
O cambiamo, come farebbero i virus
per cercare di sopravvivere:
mutano, senza uccidere l'ospite;
oppure cambiamo pianeta.
Ma credo che sia più semplice cambiare,
che cambiare pianeta.
Grazie.
(Applausi)